good morning kick it's tuesday today i
would like to tell you the story of the
unlikely survival of a book all right so
during the turtles all the way down
movie shoot i became friends with the
second assistant director tracy who's
worked on everything from like irobot to
hot tub time machine and one day we were
chatting and she revealed that she grew
up in the small town of flynn flon
manitoba now as the grandson of somebody
from skull bone tennessee i have long
been fascinated by unusual place names
and tracy explained to me that flynn
flan got its name from a novel the
sunless city published in 1905. now i
have a long-standing rule that if a
friend gives me a strange out-of-print
book i read it because you never know
when you're going to discover long-lost
wittery treasure and i told tracy about
this and then just as covid was settling
upon my house what should arrive in my
mailbox but the sunless city okay first
the author joyce emerson prestigmatic
wrote over 50 books in his lifetime he
was mostly known as an author of
detective stories like he wrote
detective stories about this glaswegian
detective called dick donovan and they
were as popular as the sherlock holmes
stories for a while but monik also wrote
travelogues and literary fiction and
true crime and a bit of sci-fi you've
probably never heard of medic i know i
haven't and it's important to remember
he's more the rule than the exception
like books don't last forever and very
very few books even last for an average
human lifespan like i've never heard of
asm hutchinson or gertrude atherton but
they wrote the best-selling american
novels of 1922 and 1923 respectively the
year the great gatsby came out these
were the 10 most popular novels in the
united states and if you've heard of
more than one of these authors you're
better read than i am in general books
for lack of a better term die young like
it is far more rare for a book to live
to 100 than it is for a person and so
there's nothing surprising about jep
medic's work being totally forgotten
what's surprising is that it's not
totally forgotten which brings us back
to the sunless city a tale of a vast and
seemingly endless lake whose secrets are
discovered by one josiah flintabaddy
flonatin a snuffin man of science and by
snuffin i mean he snorts tobacco up his
nose over and over again in the book
flinflon as he is nicknamed discovers
that the lake is a kind of portal into a
world underneath our world and he takes
this mechanical fish submarine that also
doubles as a sailboat way down deep into
the lake and then eventually comes out
in the new earth that part is really
quite exciting and in this upside down
interior world within a world everything
is paved with gold and tin is the
valuable mineral it's the one that's
used in coins and crowns and then he
discovers a great underground kingdom
with all these people who have tales and
the kingdom is run by a council of women
which flynn flan does not like now i
suppose one could read flin flon's
wildly misogynistic response to a
matriarchal society as satire but the
problem is flinfon is consistently
presented as like the smartest and most
wise man in the world and at one point
he says that if women were in the us
congress i very much fear i should be
false to my allegiance and forsake my
dear old stars and stripes so yeah
there's a reason we don't read a lot of
mark these days but to be fair the book
hasn't survived because of its story it
survived because of its protagonist's
incredible name because when a canadian
prospector named tom creighton came
across a large and deep vein of copper
he decided to name his mind the flinfon
mine because he'd just read the sun with
city and the town that grew up around
that mine came to be called flynn fawn
as well flinfon is going through a hard
time the biggest mine in the town is
closing this year but it continues on
and as long as it does the best of jep
muddock's work will also survive and i
find that kind of lovely
hank i'll see you on friday